spot I'm at homecoming track I could
only do it with like movie trailer for
spider-man homecoming has hit the
Internet as we knew it would admit it
this morning ever rose from the dead I
gotta check my phone turn after you
trailer and right off the bat we see
Peter Parker as a lot of high school
superheroes could be the coolest kid in
school not only is he doing cannonballs
in a swimming pool but he has so many
stories like when his friend finds out
he's spider-man he's like do you know
that guy who talked about Captain
America he's like still a shield right
there you know he can go to an assembly
be like hey everyone I'm spider-man
I stole Captain America's shield here's
the footage from the airport because you
saw that in the first trailer come at me
come at hi Mary Jane how you doing Oh
Glenn - life is good but it doesn't
because power of responsibility that
he'll chestnut you need continue to see
the integration of spider-man's universe
into the MCU like vulture Michael Keaton
is like rich guys like Stark they don't
care about Tony Stark has created more
enemies than he has heroes that's just a
thing and the trailer shows that in
Peter Parker's ambition could be the
hero he believes Tony Stark to be he
getting in dangers a lot of lives
yeah that's seen with the chip that
reminded you of the scene from
spider-man 2 with the train that happens
because voltar blows the thing in half
apparently and this is what I start
thinking the trailer shows it's a bit
too much it's been Tony Stark starts
giving him the parental verbal beatdown
is like give the suit back he didn't
make his suit it is his suit and Peter
Parker is like I'm nothing without the
suit he starts giving him the junk candy
from Cool Runnings speech I like if
you're not enough without it you're
never going to be enough with it nothing
without this shoe if you're nothing
about this shoe then you shouldn't have
it which is a great line that I think is
great in the trailer however I feel like
you could have just had Peter Parker say
I'm nothing without the suit yeah Tony
Stark all like if you're nothing without
the suit then you shouldn't have it
don't show us that he wants the suit
back gives him that lecture takes the
suit back and then that's why he's in
his old spider-man PJ's for that plain
saying hey I'm nitpicking I mean granted
if someone held a gun to my head all
right what's most of the movie about if
you're like a spider-man taking out the
vulture throwing that I guess I don't
know everything about the movie but I
just feel like that was a plot point I
wouldn't want to know in this trailer
the scene doesn't show how much Peter
Parker really looks up to Tony Stark I
think that's great
little Spider Man aka Simba's like I
didn't wanted to be brave like you just
could have gone for sitting in the movie
theater when I'm watching the movie like
the
in the end I think Peter Parker's
justified from this trailer anyway Tony
Stark is being like don't worry about
the flying vulture man there are people
who handle this sort of thing I'd be
like unless any other Avengers are here
right now talking to me and or taking
him down where where are these people
that take people like him down yeah good
talk chief I'm gonna go take down evil
flying bird man that plane seems great
though he's like Superman Returns got
nothing on me
however if he does snap the wing off
like Superman did in Superman Returns
those people are dead so guys in the end
Spider Man homecoming remains my movie
this summer I want to see more than
anything
bossy spider-man come home I want to see
his homecoming I want to see the
extension of the Tom Hollands scene we
saw in Civil War because it's all they
stole that thing I think it looks great
however my critique is it does feel like
a Sony spider-man trailer because it
showed way too much like the amazing
spider-man trailers did did it gone for
a bit more of a vague trailer not
showing the cause and effect of Peter
Parker screwing Tony Stark takes the
suit back and Peter Parker has
essentially a costume change yeah
there's a character moment I like saving
for the moon that's me person but
looking forward to it nonetheless so
spider-man homecoming trailer have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and if you like nerdy geeky
trivia shows this Friday I will be
competing in the movie trivia Schmo down
in or geekdom match I've done it before
but I want to throw a mulligan on this
one because last time I entered wrong
questions to questions I know the right
answers to and the [ __ ] haunts me so
I'll put a link below to the playlist
this Friday when it goes live I'll
change that link out for the link to the
actual video look for that on Friday
hours curtain cake give me the power and
as always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more good luck
[Music]